i
[Música]
ah
la respuesta de google a las denuncias
del departamento de justicia
estadounidense respecto a las supuestas
violaciones de las leyes
antimonopolistas está siendo bastante
tibia sobre todo teniendo en cuenta lo
que google se juega y es que según el
gigante tecnológico tan solo se limitan
a seguir las mismas reglas del mercado
que otras empresas y si el consumidor es
lo que desea a su buscador entonces
google no puede hacer nada al respecto
eso sí muchos no pueden evitar ver aquí
en sillicon valley una especie de
vendetta del gobierno de donald trump ya
que la mayor parte de los seguidores de
trump y dentro del mismo gabinete
aseguran estar siendo víctimas de una
especie de caza de brujas en las redes
[Música]
google tendrá que remunerar a la prensa
francesa por utilizar sus contenidos
hace cerca de un año más de 300 editores
de prensa además de la agencia france
presse denunciaron a google ante la
autoridad de la competencia y ésta falló
a su favor en el mes de abril de 2020
sin embargo google recurrió este fallo
pero ahora es el tribunal de apelación
el que ha confirmado la decisión del mes
de abril explicando por una parte que
google no solamente goza de una gran
notoriedad sino que además está en una
posición de casi monopolio en cuanto se
trata de motores de búsqueda y de
agregación de contenido ambas partes ya
se han sentado a negociar una suma que
ronda los 25 millones de euros muy lejos
de los 150 millones que se habían pedido
inicialmente pero es una decisión que
sienta un precedente muy importante a
nivel europeo además y por otra parte es
una pequeña victoria también para la
prensa francesa que en los últimos años
pues lo único que hace es generar
pérdidas ya que son los gigantes
tecnológicos los que se han quedado con
la gran parte del negocio publicitario
[Música]
la comisión europea ha montado hasta
tres veces a google por abuso de
posición dominante con sanciones que han
sido prácticamente históricas la última
vez fue el año pasado cuando la comisión
europea sancionó a google con casi 1500
millones de euros por incumplir las
normas de competencia con su plataforma
de publicidad online adsense la filial
europea de google insiste en que hasta
ahora siempre ha tratado de cumplir las
normas y obligaciones que le ha impuesto
la comisión europea pero esto no ha sido
suficiente porque los últimos tres años
bruselas ha investigado y ha sancionado
tres veces y con más de ocho mil
millones de euros a la gran tecnológica
pero esto no es lo único porque la
comisión europea sigue investigando y
actualmente está analizando un nuevo
caso por recopilación de datos
personales
[Música]